il est clair que aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national à une dynamique
pourquoi tout simplement parce que les
problèmes ne sont pas ne sont pas réglés
et que ils ont le sentiment que
peut-être avec le rassemblement national
ils le seront mieux ce qui est un leurre
et une illusion et c'est la raison pour
laquelle aux républicains avec christian
jacob
nous sommes sur le travail de fond et
sur les propositions alors ce qu'on
aurait fait de mieux c'est ce qu'on a
fait de mieux en réalité dans la gestion
de la crise sanitaire
il n'y a qu'à regarder ce que les
régions fait les régions tenues par les
républicains regardez ce que laurent
wauquiez a fait dans la région auvergne
rhône-alpes en matière de masques en
matière de vaccination en matière
d'organisation de la gestion de la crise
en matière de tests dans les
établissements enfin en matière de de
purificateurs d'air dans les écoles il
ya qu à regarder ce que les régions fait
il ya qu à regarder ce que les maires
ont fait ils ont bien souvent été à
contrario de la lenteur administrative
qui était d'une prudence excessive
parfois ou d'une absence de logistique
et de et de mise en oeuvre dans d'autres
cas les masques par exemple mais là je
voulais pas lorsque nous faisons en ce
moment parce que oui non mais moi je
vous ramène à l'ensemble de la gestion
de la crise lorsque vous nous avez dit
que les masques étaient inutiles bar on
ne vous a pas suivis en effet on a bien
fait de ne pas vous suivre lorsqu'on
vous disais qu'il fallait davantage de
tests et que les tests étaient comptés
qu'il fallait tester les professeurs
vous n'étiez pas d'accord nous avions
raison de le proposer parce que
finalement vous il est devenu les
républicains ont toujours été dans leur
rôle de faire des propositions c'est la
raison pour laquelle je conteste
absolument l'accusation d' yakafokon
parce que on a agi sur le terrain